hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on apex legends again
and today we're gonna be talking about
the lore of crypto a man who his
identity had to be abandoned after he
was blamed for crimes he did not commit
he specializes using surveillance drones
to stay in the fight and out of the
spotlight well also his neuro-link marks
enemies for him and his teammates and
then the drone unleashes emps to take
out those in a fortified position
would've been learning about everything
about crypto the motive the reason he's
even here and all that sort of stuff in
today's video so his life is likely if
you do enjoy subscribe every new get
comfy let's get started with the lore
for today's video so as a brief
description Kryptos real name age and
homeworld are unknown although we can't
already piece together his real name
we'll get into that into a little bit
but crypto is known as these
surveillance expert he specializes in
secrets he knows how to uncover them and
he knows how to keep them a brilliant
hacker and encryption expert he uses
aerial drones to spy on his opponents in
the apex arena without being seen it's
been noted that his drones have a
similar design to those created by the
wanted murderer tasia on park although
it has not been confirmed yet orphans
raised on the streets of suit alma jay
tune and his foster sister
Milla Alexander escaped a life of
squalor by becoming computer engineers
they designed drones that transmit the
apex games throughout the Outlands by
one day typhoon disappeared with an
important company secret and his sister
vanished under mysterious and violent
circumstances however crypto claims to
have no contact with this person and the
case remains unsolved
Kryptos motives for joining the apex
games were almost as mysterious as the
man himself in recent interviews he
claims he is seeking justice but for
what exactly remains unknown they've
already given us the name of the
character tej hoon I believe that's
pronounced completely wrong what I'm
just gonna call him Tay Tay Park here is
the K is the actual name for crypto with
his foster sister being Mila Alexander
as for why his name is unknown or why
it's been decrypted and stuff like that
we're gonna get into that a little bit
later in the video but for his abilities
he has his tactical his passive and his
ultimate for his abilities he has the
tactical drone that allows you to view
the surrounding area from above if the
drone is destroyed there is a 40 second
cooldown before you can deploy another
one for his passive which is called
neuro-link enemies detected by said
surveillance drone within 30 meters of
your position are marked for you and
your teammates to see and for the
ultimate your surveillance drone sets
off an EMP blast let's store a shield
damage slows enemies and disables traps
so you definitely want to keep that
tactical drone up and the surveillance
turn up and such because you don't want
to get that destroyed is a very long
cooldown and it's mostly his entire kit
but there's also a couple things that
were paired up with crypto we have a
text message that is potentially going
to another person within the the apex
legends arena and then we also have a
video kind of explaining the lore of the
character in the backstory so for the
video
we have Mila who is his foster sister
eating and looking at her phone while
Krypto is talking about a new security
protocol that just came up and it's not
complying with his dynastic s' Mila
tells him to run the interface package
she gave him and run in the decryption
what they found was an algorithm for the
apex games that was based off
probability and it chooses who has the
most success of winning by basing off
who the legend is what the chances of
winning are for them just before the
match even starts weapon drops that are
going to be happening within the match
and then who gets first blood it finds
the average of the highest legend to
determine who has the most success of
winning Krypto mentions that basically
whoever could get this online could skew
matches and get all the options
displayed to them right away
Mila suggest using it and Krypto is
completely against it she says this
could be their second chance they both
live poor lives since they're orphans
such as the definition of squalor so
they could finally be out of poverty
with this information and this knowledge
Krypto wants to do stuff the honest way
while Mila doesn't mind getting her
hands dirty a little bit it's unclear
what this could potentially do for them
maybe this was a way to expose syndicate
for rigging certain games or this could
be a way for a syndicate to show that
they were exposed also as well for the
gambling chances possibly an apex game
betting arenas
now it's profits unclear if betting is
actually a lot of for the apex games but
seeing as in real life we have such
popular sports that are nationwide or
even within the whole country or if it
just happens to be very local
there's betting all over the place or
whether that be legal or illegal so it's
obviously with it being deployed
everywhere throughout the Outlands
there's probably somewhere where bedding
is existing whether that also be legal
or illegal it's probably not
Farfetch'd to assume that syndicate is
probably using this for gambling chances
there are more money for the company in
news headline reads girl abducted
neighbors heard screams from apartments
breaking story
normally the death of a typical girl
wouldn't be tragically in the headline
news but Milla Alexander was far from
her typical girl she built up a
reputation in some circle as an expert
hacker and has three pending charges
against her for fraudulent online
activity her latest activity breaking
into the highly firewalled network of
the mercenary syndicate itself
eyewitnesses described blood-curdling
screams in the middle of the night and
one particular witness who says he saw a
man of Asian origins leaving the scene
of the crime syndicate mercenaries
landed in town first thing the next
morning and hon for the prime suspect
began another picture up another picture
comes up shortly afterwards of Kryptos
face and it says syndicate hunts hacker
killer seeing the syndicate close to
revealing killer's name the text at the
bottom is the exact same is the first
but it's basically proving that
syndicate is probably framing crypto for
what is happening the rest of the video
is crypto escaping the syndicate so in
an effort to fully evade suspicion he
changed his names gets rid of all of his
info and changes his appearance the more
well-known apex legend crypto on top of
that there's also a text message that
the apex legends Twitter had actually
sent out one day as just a little bit of
a tease for the character there now in
this this is actually a small video that
I will show you you can tell that the
text message is actually glitching out
and showing certain words and then
disappearing it's kind of like code
words in a sense so for example you're
see stuff like party or people who frame
me but it's actually says woman of my
dreams and then syndicate stuff like
that you're gonna be seeing that a lot
in here but thankfully someone on
Twitter called apex legend Intel or at
Apex Intel actually has the entire
message decrypted so I'm going to read
that right now and the whole message the
cryptid says as I'm sure you heard I
took your advice and went to the games
it's the only way to get close to the
people that framed me all I had to do
was distract the syndicate long enough
to get Kryptos credentials into the
system you were right about the
qualifying matches I looked into it and
there's no way I could have gotten it so
I went with Plan B I
took down the repulsor tower I had no
idea it would be so insane I was hoping
the damage was enough to close Kings
Canyon as you're well aware in the
beginning of season two I believe with
Watson there was the repulsor Tower
being blown up and it was in that
cutscene of some dude holding some type
of laptop we already knew at the
beginning that that was a new character
but we had no idea that his name would
be Krypto or that he would be some other
type of character within the universe so
now that we have that confirmed that's
pretty nice to know and his motive as
why he did that the rest of the message
reads so I can hitch a ride off the
dropship on the drop ship off solace and
find the evidence I need somewhere a new
dawn I'm just hoping this isn't like the
last time and I don't get blown up
before I go off planet sorry paranoia
leads to gallows humor thank you for
always being the mom I needed I'll be in
touch try not to worry too much what's
that you always say it's hard to be
scared when you're prepared now it's
unclear as to who he is speaking to it
could possibly be his sister or someone
whose identity is unknown and that's
really about it and that's all we really
know about Krypto definitely let me know
in the comments below what you guys
think if you guys have any other
additional information maybe some other
theories or anything like that if we
leave it in the comments below leave a
like as well if you enjoyed this video
and always if you have seen something or
that or know something that I
potentially have not uncovered yet
definitely let me know in the comments
below so we can piece this whole story
together and the yeah respawn is doing a
really good job of making the story
actually feel interesting for this game
and I like that and the way that all
these characters have very different
origin stories is really cool so like I
said definitely let me know in the
comments below about anything about this
video whether it be a theory or
something that I missed or as well as
likes if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new I covered the lore for apex
legends and as always take care guys
enjoy season 3 peace out
[Music]
you